my name is carmella Garzon I am at the
University of Rochester
I study sedimentology and tectonics and
I've always been curious about how
mountains form the central Andes is made
up of a broad very high plateau framed
by high peaks on the west and the east
so one of the goals of our current
project is to understand this growth
history of the Andes and its influence
on the extremely high biodiversity of an
Amazon you can think about the growth of
the Andes as a species pump that adds
biodiversity to the lowland Amazon
forests we've studied the AOD Basin
because it records a long history of
sedimentation over a time period where
there's evidence of dramatic surface
uplift and the tree that we visited
today is a very large tree that doesn't
exist anywhere at four kilometre
elevations the tree is about ten million
years old and the significance is that
we're in a climate that was potentially
much lower somewhat wetter but really
nothing like the cold arid climate of
the four kilometer high plateau today
you